this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos created by
nucleus medical media to apply for a
free 30-day trial click on the link in
the description
if you have stress urinary incontinence
your doctor may advise you to have a
tension free vaginal tape or tvt
procedure
stress urinary incontinence means your
bladder leaks urine during physical
activity
to start the procedure the surgeon will
make two small incisions in your abdomen
just above your pubic bone
another small incision will be made in
your vagina
a needle will be passed through this
incision into your body and out of one
of the incisions in your abdomen
a mesh tape attached to the needle will
be pulled along this path
then a needle attached to the other end
of the tape will repeat this procedure
on the other side
once the tape is in place your surgeon
will adjust it around your urethra to
provide support
the ends of the tape will be cut just
beneath your skin
at the end of the procedure the vaginal
incision will be closed with sutures
and the pubic incisions may be closed
with surgical glue or sutures
after the procedure the tape will
support your urethra and prevent urine
leakage
over time scar tissue forms around the
tape to hold it in place
to find out more about attention-free
vaginal tape procedure talk to your
healthcare provider